c'est frédéric péchenard bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france manque des républicains on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
christelle bertrand jean christelle la
dépêche merci d'être avec nous on va
continuer à parler de ces questions de
sécurité vous êtes un spécialiste de ces
questions frédéric péchenard et du
séminaire gouvernemental avait lieu hier
sur ce sujet questions de sécurité
question de lutte contre le séparatisme
aussi on va en parler
la france est malade de son insécurité
dit le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin qu'est ce que vous pensez vous
de la méthode darmanin
je pense qu'il a raison on a un problème
d'insécurité en france la sécurité ça
toujours été un problème depuis j'ai été
policier pendant pendant plus de trente
ans donc c'est des sujets que je connais
bien ça a été toute toute ma vie d'homme
mais en ce moment on voit bien que
depuis quelques années il ya une montée
de la violence dans le pays
je vous donne un exemple le nombre des
homicides en france a diminué de moitié
entre 1990 et 2012 donc un pays où on
tue deux fois moins et est un pays qui
me semblait être sur la voie d'un
certain apaisement et bien depuis 2014
le nombre d'homicides repart à la hausse
alors certes nous avons eu des attentats
terroristes mai 2019 et la plus mauvaise
année de ces dernières années si j'ose
dire et il ya une augmentation de 9 %
des homicides par rapport à dernière or
ce sont des chiffres qui sont importants
parce que les homicides il ya on cdc des
sujets qui sont particulièrement graves
c'est évidemment le sommet de la
violence et c'est enfin des choses qu'on
connaît très bien
voyez dans le même temps une
augmentation des coups et blessures
volontaires et également une
augmentation des agressions sexuelles et
des viols
comment vous explique mais exactement
mais il faut faire attention que je
m'excuse et moi quand on compare levé
par exemple de l'augmentation des
plaintes pour viol on ne sait jamais
trop dire s'il ya réellement une
augmentation des viols ou si ce qui est
une mauvaise nouvelle ou si ce qui
pourrait être une bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'il ya plus de femmes qui portent
plainte
par contre c'est pour ça que prend des
homicides c'est un item qui est très
intéressant parce que on voit bien qu'il
ait une augmentation des violences
depuis quelques années dans notre pays
c'est d'ailleurs pas seulement dans
notre pays ça qu'on s'aperçoit que c'est
un phénomène qui touche un certain
nombre de pays de beats de l'occident et
puis on a bien vu aussi que par exemple
des assad de manifestations je pense au
gd jaune mais pas uniquement au gilet
jaune
tournent à peu près systématiquement à
la violence ce qui était beaucoup moins
le cas il ya quelques années et beaucoup
moins le cas quand j'étais moi-même
directeur général de la police nationale
quand nicolas sarkozy était présent la
république quand vous expliquer cette
augmentation des chiffres responsabilité
de l'état où est ce que la société
change alors je c'est une c'est une très
bonne question et si on savait y
répondre ma foi je pense qu'on
arriverait assez rapidement à comprendre
et à circonscrire le phénomène
probablement quand même on peut
considérer que ça va avec la perte de
l'autorité de l'état
dire que petit à petit on voit bien que
les symboles de l'état sont de plus en
plus contesté alors non seulement bien
sûr les policiers les gendarmes
on voit en plus en plus de difficulté
sont attaqués mais également les
pompiers mais également les maires etc
donc on a une perte globale de tracts et
de l'état on a un recul de la république
et ce sont des phénomènes qui sont très
inquiétants quand on vit dans une
république
quand les républicains ce que je suis
con et démocrates ce que je suis bien
sûr c'est également mais on voit bien
que lien il ya un sujet alors moi je
pense que parce qu'une fois qu'on a posé
ce diagnostic faut essayer de trouver
une solution
je pense que la première la première
difficulté c'est j'allais dire l'absence
de sanction c'est pas vrai naturellement
mais les difficultés de sanctionner et
le fait que de plus en plus de personnes
pensent qu'ils sont intouchables ou
qu'ils échappent à la sanction
or non clairement trop de laxisme j'aime
pas trop le mot laxisme parce que vous
avez j'ai toujours entendu dire toute ma
vie de policier les policiers arrêtent
et magistrats relâche ce n'est pas vrai
les policiers arrêtent les magistrats
condamnent mais c'est après qu'il ya un
problème dans l'exécution de la peine
donner quelques exemples quand vous êtes
condamné à une peine de travail
d'intérêt général par exemple en france
par un tribunal
je rappelle que quand une condamnation
ce sont des magistrats professionnels
qui sont indépendants qui prononce cette
peine dans le cadre d'un procès public
avec un avocat un procureur fasse qu est
ce qu on appelle un état de droit donc
ces panels doivent être exécutés sinon
il n'y a plus d'état de droit en ce qui
concerne les amendes
la moitié des amendes seulement sont
recouvrées en ce qui concerne les peines
de travail d'intérêt général qu'il
pleuvait des très bonnes peines
notamment pour les pour les
primo-délinquants pour les jeunes
délinquants
eh bien vous avez que 20% des peines qui
ne
sont pas effectués et sur celles qui
sont effectuées la moyenne c'est 4 119
jours
d'accord vous avez 16 ans que vous avez
volé une bobine est tout à fait une
bêtise
vous êtes condamné une peine de travail
d'intérêt général vous allez la faire un
an et demi après objectivement cédera
beaucoup de sens et ce qui est vrai pour
les pour les amendes et pour les peines
de tg est vrai également pour les
prisons puisque bas quand vous êtes
condamné alors d'abord les peines de
moins de six mois de prison ferme sont
maintenant impossible mais quand vous
êtes condamnés à moins d'un an de prison
ferme
quoi qu'il arrive vous n'y allez pas
donc quel qu'est-ce que vous envoyez moi
je ne suis pas vous savez beccaria a dit
ce qui est important d'une peine c'est
pas sa sévérité
c'est sa certitude c'est d'ailleurs
cette parole a été repris par le premier
ministre jean castex
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ça moi
je suis pas quelqu'un qui demandent des
peines sévères
je suis quelqu'un qui demande que quand
une peine est décidée elle soit
appliquée le gouvernement dit vouloir
travailler sur cette question des peines
avec les collectivités locales est ce
que c'est le bon échelon
à votre avis alors sans aucun doute sur
les peines de travail d'intérêt général
c'est aux collectivités territoriales
d'aidé et de prendre en compte les tgv
moi c'est quelque chose auquel je crois
beaucoup
naturellement pour les peines de prison
ça peut être que quelque chose à faire
est gagnant mais quel signal vous
envoyez à quelqu'un quand vous le
condamné à un an de prison ferme
je pense par exemple aux boxeurs qui
avait frappé les deux gendarmes dans le
cas du manifestant ddj des jaunes et que
cette personne ne va pas en prison parce
que la peine est systématiquement
aménagé on voit bien que ça c'est rod
vous avez des gens qui ont été arrêtés
15 fois vingt fois par la police soit
parce qu'ils étaient mineurs
soit parce que les faits n'étaient pas
si graves soit parce qu'ils ont
bénéficié sur six soit parce qu'ils ont
été condamnés à moins d'un an de prison
ferme qui n'ont jamais été en prison
comment voulez vous que les gens
comprennent et comment voulez-vous que
l'autorité de l'état soit affirmée voilà
donc la hausse c'est la première chose
qu'il faut faire je pense c'est la
certitude de la sanction
quand vous faites quand vous faites une
infraction quelle qu'elle soit ça peut
être un feu rouge c'est peut-être
quelque chose de très grave
vous devez être sanctionné cette
sanction et doit être juste il doit être
proportionnelle naturellement j'ai
jamais fait partie des gens qui
voulaient des des sanctions est
épouvantable et mais quand vous êtes
condamné vous devez d'affaires et alors
on voit bien que
aujourd'hui gouvernement un vrai
problème c'est qu'il ya une partie du
monde de dijon de la gauche judiciaire
qui considère que ça il faut un numerus
clausus dans les prisons voilà alors on
le dit pas exactement comme ça mais
c'est la réalité c'est-à-dire qu'on
attend de places de prison
on doit pas avoir plus de détenus c'est
pour cette cité qui est trois quatre
cinq personnes partiel et ça s'entend en
terme de gestion des prisons mais ça ne
s'entend pas du tout en terme de
sanction et en termes d'état de droit
sert que si a passé deux passés en
prison il faut en construire là
aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est que vous ne pouvez rentrer
en prison que si quelqu'un en sort ce
qui fait que déjà on voit que pour la
sanction au départ quand vous rentrez
sais pas si simple puisque vous êtes
condamné vous n'allez pas y aller mais
vous êtes condamné à deux ans de prison
et vous n'allez pas les faire parce
qu'il ya un moment où à faire sortir
plus tôt on a bien vu d'ailleurs au
moment du duc au vide le misa justice a
à libérer 13000 un peu plus de 13000 des
+ 20 % des détenus
on nous l'a vendu en audience et des
femmes peinent naturellement c'est pas
vrai 20% des femmes des détenus c'est
pas des gens qui étaient à 15 jours de
la sortie
bon ces gens là évidemment ne sont plus
en prison donc la gestion à l'intérieur
de la prison s'en trouve facilitée mais
par contre ils sont de nouveau à
l'extérieur et je ne suis pas sûr que la
totalité d'entre eux aient décidé de
s'acheter une conduite
on va parler des agressions d'élus elles
sont nombreuses à 1 233 déjà depuis le
début de l'année gabriel atta le porte
parole du gouvernement a parlé hier de
ces questions et les sujets séminaire
gouvernemental on va l'écouter vous fait
réagir juste après nous aurons dans les
prochaines semaines sous l'autorité du
premier ministre
un travail avec les collectivités
locales pour rendre plus efficaces les
sanctions les sons des sanctions plus
proche du terrain des sanctions
effectués effectivement avec le
développement de sanctions éducatives de
travaux d'intérêt général quand c'est
nécessaire et que nous aurons une
augmentation du budget de la justice qui
a été annoncé par le premier ministre
qui a notamment parlé d'une mesure qui
est le recrutement de greffiers de
magistrats pour rendre notre système
judiciaire plus efficace mais qui
permettra le financement et le
déploiement d'autres mesures qui seront
à cette occasion annoncé par le premier
ministre et le garde des sceaux
donc ça c'est le rappel
des annonces qui doivent être faites
dans les semaines à venir sur les
sanctions l'effectivité des sanctions
mais sur ces agressions d'élus dont il a
été aussi question hier il ya notamment
une circulaire qui a été publié en début
de semaine par le garde des sceaux eric
dupond moretti et qui demande aux
procureurs de durcir les poursuites à
l'encontre des agresseurs d'élus locaux
est ce que pour vous cette circulaire
est suffisante
je fais maintenant c'est une bonne chose
incontestablement mais quand vous
entendez je suis attal qui essaye
d'expliquer qu'en fait il hier aucune
décision n'était prise
finalement ce séminaire vous m'avez
invité pour parler du séminaire sur la
sécurité voilà c'est même pas la
montagne qui accouche d'une souris sa
montagne qui accouche de rien du tout
donc on a parlé de tout sauf de sécurité
j'ai écouté monsieur attal et j'ai rien
trouvé de nouveau ni de particuliers
mais finalement on a besoin de quoi on a
besoin d'abord d'une parole politique
forte
vous avez vous n'arrivez si on reste
dans le domaine de la sécurité mais de
ça pour être dans d'autres domaines
vous ne pouvez arriver à quelque chose
dans un pays comme le nôtre que si le
président de la république lui-même
s'impliquent
alors t'as que quand nicolas sarkozy est
devenu ministre de l'intérieur on était
dans une situation politique sécuritaire
qui était compliqué donc il a fait un
travail remarquable
je vous rappelle quand même que pendant
dix ans la délinquance a baissé en
france dans notre pays mais il avait à
mizdah justice qui travaillait avec lui
il avait également un président de
république était d'accord on sortait de
just un premier ministre qui avait je
rappelle que monsieur jospin n'a pas été
au deuxième tour probablement d'ailleurs
à cause de l'insécurité et de la notion
de mou du sentiment d'insécurité et
c'est un mot qui est terrible sentiment
d'insécurité pas ce que ça veut dire aux
gens en fait c'est le fantasme de
sécurité c'est un sentiment mais c'est
pas vrai vous n'avez pas été tech et
vous n'avez pas peur n'aie pas été
violée on n'a pas cassé votre voiture
c'est un sentiment voilà et c'est
insupportable pour les gens qui ont subi
ça et même pour les gens qu'ils n'ont
pas subi le simple fait d'avoir peur
c'est pas un fantasme d'avoir peur quand
vous avez peur même s'il n'arrive rien
c'est que quelque part l'état a failli
voilà c'est pour ça que c'est faux
jamais parlé à mon sens de sentiment
d'insécurité parce que les gens prennent
mal parce que dit ah oui d'accord mais
si j'ai peur c'est que je suis un
trouillard
c'est un fantasme voilà donc il n'y a
pas de sentiment d'insécurité il ya de
l'insécurité elle est réelle elle
augmente elle doit être maîtrisable
encore faut-il qu'on en prenne
conscience
je considère que certaines tout de même
enfin je constate que ça fait trois ans
que manet de maquereaux un président de
la république et que finalement il s'est
peu exprimé sur ces sujets et qui là et
qu'on a peu avancé vous savez dans le
domaine de la sécurité
le en même temps ça peut pas marcher
d'ailleurs vous pouvez pas avoir en même
temps un ministre de l'intérieur qui dit
je vais être ferme et impitoyable et de
l'autre côté un ministre de la justice
qui explique que doit y avoir personne
dans les prisons vous pouvez pas
conduire une voiture avec à la fois le
pied sur l'accélérateur le pied sur le
frein c'est j'ai l'impression c'est un
petit peu ce qui est en train de se
passer aujourd'hui vous avez le
sentiment que le ministre la justice
détricote un peu le discours que gérald
darmanin essaye de essaye de poser le
constat que gérald r bien sûr on voit
bien qu'il ya ils sont pas du tout
d'accord
idéologiquement parlant voilà il ya
vraiment une vraie différence dès le
matin des difficultés que des manuels
macron vis-à-vis de ces questions de
sécurité
cette dichotomie entre ministre de
l'intérieur et j'ai bien sûr que ça peut
pas fonctionner ça peut pas fonctionner
faut que faut que tout le monde soit
d'accord jeu
je pars reprendre euh bon exemple mais
il faut que tout le monde aille dans le
même sens alors après on peut avoir des
sensibilités différentes 1 c'est bien
sûr mais vous ne pouvez pas vouloir
aujourd'hui rétablir l'autorité de
l'état
faire en sorte que vos policiers ne
soient plus agressive aux gendarmes
soient pu agresser que vos mères ne soit
plus agressés uniquement avec des belles
paroles il faut une volonté politique
forte et derrière il faut des peines et
une fois de plus ses peines
elles ont pas besoin extrêmement sévère
il s'agit pas d'envoyer des gens dix ans
en prison
il s'agit que quand quelqu'un est
condamné à une peine et bien elle soit
exécutée immédiatement
alors en revanche éludé annonce un peu
plus précise sur le séparatisme la lutte
contre le séparatisme depuis quelques
jours un projet de loi est prévu dans
les prochaines semaines et parmi les
mesures qui devraient être contenues
dans ce projet de loi il ya les un
contrat d'engagement sur la laïcité pour
les associations avec le fait que plus
aucun argent public ne sera versée aux
associations ennemis de la république
pour reprendre les mots du gouvernement
est ce que vous voterez ce projet de loi
alors malheureusement je ne voterai pas
parce que je fais les républicains en
tout cas de voter ce projet de l'enjeu
je ne peux pas vous le dire
moi j'y suis très favorable juste savoir
une fois de plus c'est un projet de loi
qui est sûr dont on parle depuis plus
d'un an
il me semble qu'il ya une certaine
urgence à le faire c'est moi je suis
vous l'avez dit vice président à la
région dit valérie pécresse et a été élu
la première chose qu'on a faite c'est de
créer la fac rêve de créer d'imposer une
charte de la laïcité c'est à dire que
évidemment la région comme toutes les
collectivités donne des subventions des
associations et bien dès 2015
dès fin 2015 nous avons dit voilà ces
subventions elles ne seront donnés que
si vous vous engagez vous signer une
charte de la laïcité
donc c'est quelque chose et c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne bien qui
est efficace pour des raisons d'ailleurs
relativement incompréhensible pour moi
une partie de la gauche et des
écologistes sont violemment hostile et
d'ailleurs systématiquement à toutes les
commissions permanentes de man que cette
charte soit retirée je n'ai jamais bien
compris pourquoi la vérité c'est que
c'est un outil qui est extrêmement utile
justement pour éviter de donner de
l'argent public à des associations qui
ne reconnaissent pas la république que
celle bertrand pour pour changer de
sujet basson à la crise sanitaire
hier le professeur delfraissy a annoncé
que le gouvernement
bon allez devoir dans les prochains
jours prendre des décisions difficiles
est-ce que vous comment vous jugez
l'action du gouvernement jusqu'à présent
sur cette crise sanitaire est ce que
vous avez le sentiment qu'il fait ce
qu'il
ce qu'il doit faire et qu'elle est bien
gérée alors c'est une crise qui est très
difficile à gérer les d'ailleurs la
critique est toujours facile et en
l'occurrence je vais être un peu plus
prudent que ce que la critique que je
vais sur l'insécurité
d'abord c'est une crise qui est mondial
et c'est intéressant de voir comment les
autres gèrent et finalement s'aperçoit
que peu ou prou basse et c'est facile
nulle part voilà donc ça c'est la
première chose qu'on peut dire est que
globalement la crise est gérée après je
partage l'opinion de mon prédécesseur
ici quelques instants l'erreur
fondamentale du départ de la gestion de
la crise ça a été les mensonges sur le
masque terre dire que la porte parole du
gouvernement a expliqué que le match
servait à rien que même c'était
dangereux
on a interdit le port du masque aux
policiers la région ile-de-france a
acheté 30 millions de masques qu'on a
distribué les extraits lus aux ehpad en
10 rue aux mairies on a distribué et on
a voulu en donner au ministère de
l'intérieur
le ministre de l'intérieur pas gérald
harlin le précédent a refusé les masques
c'est que pour que les policiers
puissent cette équipe et j'ai été
obligée moi même de les donner aux
syndicats de police parce que le
ministère de le refuser
donc on est parti de ce mensonge le mas
ne sert à rien pour camoufler une vérité
qui était nous n'avons pas de masque et
aujourd'hui on a des masques on
s'aperçoit qu'il obligatoire partout
voilà donc ça pose des problèmes parce
que c'était un mensonge une
communication mensongère qui évidemment
entache maintenant toute la
communication du gouvernement
en plus de ça et on le comprend cette
communication ll est erratique
parce que on change du jour au lendemain
le masque était était obligatoire à
paris quand elle est oubliée toit est
obligatoire pour tout le monde y compris
les cyclistes et ceux qui courent est
finalement sous la pression de la mairie
de paris il est plus obligatoire pour
les cyclistes
mais il reste obligatoire pour les gens
en scooter moi je suis venu aujourd'hui
en scooter j'ai un casque intégral sous
le casque intégral je suis obligée de
mettre un masque
alors que mon voisin à côté qui était en
vélo et qui lui peut cracher partout
n'avait pas de masque enfin on comprend
pas toujours bien la décision ce qui me
frappe c'est finalement la place
qu'après le conseil scientifique au nom
de quoi le conseil scientifique
s'exprime le conseil scientifique il est
au tour du président de la république
autour des décideurs politiques
ils sont là pour donner des conseils et
sont pas là pour s'exprimer moi
j'attends une prise de parole des
responsables politiques le responsable
le le patron le bass le chef dans notre
pays c'est le président de la république
c'est à lui prend des décisions jean
françois delfraissy n'aurait pas dû
s'exprimer avant le conseil de défense
qui aura lieu vendredi mais absolument
je comprends pas pourquoi les gens
s'expriment ici on part à mon sens ils
surent pas là pour ça les décisions
doivent être prises par le président de
la république
cette crise et les sanitaires c'est vrai
mais d'abord elle ne concerne pas que le
vide
on sait que par exemple à 62 personnes
ne n'ont pas été détectés de leur cancer
n'ont pas été dicté à ce nombre de
maladies à cause du club local et une
crise sanitaire qui est plus vaste que
le coc vide et puis on est aussi une
crise économique
on a une crise politique qu'on a une
prise démocratique on voit bien que ça
pose à sa noble de problème donc
évidemment le conseil scientifique lui
on lui demande de prendre des options
parce que vous pouvez pas tout savoir
sur le l'évolution du que vides mais la
décision que d'une décision plus
complexe et bien elle doit être prise et
exclusivement par l'opposant de
république mais vous attend des
décisions fermes face à un nombre de
contaminations qui augmente mais surtout
nombre de personnes à l'hôpital et
aurait une mission qui augmente tant que
les jeux je sais pas trop où j'allais
moi je suis pas un spécialiste
on voit bien la légion l'animation donc
comment la région ile-de-france qui est
particulièrement touché 1 se prépare
alors nous on a été très réactif puisque
dès le le tout début alors qu'il n'est
pas de masque en france alors que
valérie pécresse a décidé que bien que
ce soit pas directement notre notre
travail qu'on allait faire venir des
masques on à les protéger des champs
donc on a mis ça je suis assez sûr les
masses mais ce que par exemple vous
préparez un recond finement ciblée est
ce que vous l'envisagez on envisage tout
et notamment à la région proprement dit
on a tout de suite été en télétravail
tout le monde était en télétravail on a
été un des premiers à avoir des
à l'intérieur de la région des
circulations du gel etc
et puis on s'est débrouillé pour acheter
30 millions de masques on a fait venir
et qu'on a distribués
donc on est très en pointe et on suit on
suit ça là où on voit aussi c'est que
les références ont un peu changé
dire que pendant confinement ce qui
était important nous expliquait-on
c'était pas le nombre de cas c'était le
nombre de personnes en réanimation et
nombre de morts donc ce qu'on donnait
c'était les animations et des morts
aujourd'hui c'est un peu changé c'est le
nombre de personnes contaminées
on voit bien qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
moins de gens qui meurent tant mieux
beaucoup moins de gens en réanimation
tant mieux qu'il ya quand même une
tendance à la hausse qui est
relativement inquiétant mais que je ne
sais pas juger et sur le nombre de
personnes qui ont le qui sont positifs
au co vide évidemment c'est probablement
lié à une nouvelle circulation du virus
c'est lié aussi au fait que contestent
de plus en plus voilà donc je je
j'entends des médecins qui disent qu'il
ya un risque et un danger
j'ai tendance à leur faire confiance
même si les chiffres ne me paraissent
pas extrêmement alarmants aujourd'hui
c'est quand tous les maths quand tous
les jours vous annoncer le nombre de
blessés enfin le nombre de gens touchés
le nombre de gens hospitalisés le genre
langue le gf38 s'est c'est très
angoissant finalement et je ressens
cette angoisse comme tout le monde il ya
1600 personnes qui meurent tous les
jours
si tous les jours on égrénait le nombre
de morts de mort du cancer par exemple
ça je cours us à terrifier les gens
alors entre la nécessaire information
des français parce qu'il faut qu'ils
sachent qu'il faut qu'il soit
responsable et il faut trouver un
équilibre pour pas trop angoissé les
gens non plus voilà sais c'est pas si
simple
et c'est vrai que le gouvernement à
faire face à quelque chose qui est
difficile
alors frédéric péchenard ce week-end les
gilets jaunes s'apprête à redescendre
dans la rue
est-ce qu'il faut autoriser ces
manifestations eu égard au contexte
sanitaire bien sûr et au contexte
économique
alors on voit bien que c'est une très
bonne question et c'est ce que je
10 m qui peut tout à l'heure cette crise
elle n'est pas que sanitaire elle est
politique et démocratique
alors d'un côté vous avez l'interdiction
de réunions dans la rue ou g ou chez les
personnes vous avez le port du masque
obligatoire zèle et distanciation
sociale bon ça on a bien compris de
l'autre on est aussi dans un pays
démocratique on est aussi dans un pays
où le droit de manifester quelque chose
je si on parle du gilet jaune le droit
de manifester pour moi c'est pas le
droit de le casser de mettre le feu et à
ces deux choses sont différentes c'est
des manifestants vous avez des émeutiers
ne peuvent pas être traitées pareil moi
je pense qu'il faut autoriser les
manifestations à certaines conditions et
notamment que les gens qui viennent
manifester soit des gens qui soient
responsables c'est à dire que vous venez
manifester mais vous devez porter un
masque
vous devez garder à distance des
distances on peut le faire en marchant
il est temps avec des rangs qui sont un
petit peu clairsemé etc etc
voilà donc il ya un équilibre à trouver
moi je pense qu'un gouvernement peut pas
interdire toute la manifestation sous le
prétexte du coc vide mais d'un autre
côté il faut que chacun fasse attention
publique
oui on a envie de vous demander
aujourd'hui comment va la droite
françois baroin ne s'est toujours pas
exprimée sur cette décision concernant
la question des primaires et sur le est
sur la table du départage est ce que
vous y êtes favorable donc pas de
primaires plutôt un départage entre les
différents candidats
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous savez
hier on avait une réunion de l'équipe
dirigeante aux parties la première chose
qu'on a décidé c'est pas en parler c'est
à dire que on va se focaliser une vague
après l'autre on vient de passer les
municipales qui sont plutôt bien placés
pour les républicains
on le verra d'ailleurs aux sénatoriales
dans dans quelques jours je pense qu'on
va conserver notre majorité au sénat
on a une rentrée qui contrairement à ce
qui a été dit a été une bonne rentrée
avec des jeunes j'ai participé et plus
de mille repas qui ont été servis le
vendredi soir donc c'était plutôt pas
mal bon maintenant on a quand même
en ligne de mire direct les régionales
et départementales
nous avons des positions fortes
notamment dans les régions et dans les
départements
il faut absolument qu'on les cons les
conservent donc ont franchement pour
l'instant notre but numéro un ce sont
les régionales et les départementales
qui ne sont d'ailleurs pas
si simple puisque un certain nombre de
présidents de région qui était l air en
sont sortis mais il faut quand même
partie de notre famille politique
donc on verra après avril 2021
comment on fait il faudra avoir un
processus de sélection pour notre
candidat ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que les républicains présenteront un
candidat
ça c'est ce que je suis en parlait pas
voilà alors après sujet est clos le
sujet à la fin des élections absolument
locale